if we can mute ourselves i'd love to
hear from from mark see what mark's been
up to this week i know he's always
keeping busy
so uh get yourselves get yourself get
yourselves muted
i'll be jumping in i've got lots to say
i've got lots to ask if you've got
questions and if you suck i'd love to
i'd love to hear from you
uh we'll start just a couple minutes
early today and uh
go on mark what's what's uh what's been
going down this week
hey buddy how's it going you're right
how's how's life with three
life's good you know what i i yesterday
i actually um
i've just got home i've been away the
last two or three days so
i got that like 20 minutes ago but yeah
the kids seem good
yeah good good i'm glad man three
three's crazy
three children's crazy i've got three
myself so i know
yeah um yeah no it's it's been a bit a
bit of a crazy week really
um i got my planning permission through
today
which is really exciting great so that
i had to make some amendments which is a
bit of a shame
um but the new design is great it's it
still
adds the best part of 240 square meters
that's what's about 3 000 square foot to
the property um
so yeah really really pleased with that
that that's really really good
um yeah mate it's been a good week
youtube's been crazy since you put up
your um your fun little video
yeah last week we had our online online
war
it was that what that was i think it was
it felt a bit friendly
to find a war it was a friendly war it
was a friendly war
a friendly war yeah yeah yeah for sure
that's great i feel about finding
permission
um give us give us a couple top tips and
getting planning permission
um so for me it was it was working with
a good architect
um and then understanding the issues
that the council faced
so i i i i built a very good
relationship with the planning officer
and just tried to understand
exactly what what their challenges were
and what they would allow me to do and
what they wouldn't allow me to do
so i approached it from a pretty sort of
inquisitive
standpoint um so
they didn't want the new
extension to be larger than the existing
house three square meters smaller than
the existing house
we're talking a very small amount of
difference
right and um yeah i think really it's
down to communication working with a
good architect
and then ultimately making sure that the
vision is strong
um and you sell that in yeah absolutely
but it's a people
it's a people thing right same as
everything else it's people think it is
when you're dealing with the council
even as people think so um
yeah no that's great man awesome stuff
well thanks
thanks for that we've got over 100
people on the call now
i mean last week we had almost we had
almost 200 people on the call which was
which was awesome
so um yeah so the purpose of these calls
is for people to
um celebrate successes um also
ask questions if they get stuck i have
got a special guest with me tonight i've
actually got
a wonderful lady without this lady
i wouldn't be in property in fact
without this lady
no i don't think that's extreme without
this lady i wouldn't even exist
you know i wouldn't even mom and you
could yeah exactly you could probably
get it that's my mom
so i'm um this is this is sue i'm with
my mum right now
and actually i'll tell you something
[Music]
i'll tell you something really
interesting about my mom okay a couple
things so number one
is she was a real support and a rock in
order
when i when i initially got into
property so i have to have to credit for
that
but also you know she's actually killing
it right now in property
you know she's really doing some crazy
deals
and i said i was like mom you know can i
can i
can i come and vlog like some of your
projects because they're really really
quite impressive
and i actually went down and i
documented a little thing so you'll be
seeing stuff on youtube soon
um and then i said to her i said i said
hey mom i said
you know how like when i started in
property one of the reasons that helped
me succeed in property was having a
family that was supportive and having
people i could talk to and
you know i think it's really important
to have you know a supportive network
and she says yeah i said you know how
i've kind of like created that
for you know hundreds of people on the
samuel 365 she says yes
could you come in on that like could you
come in can you share can i can you come
and she's actually taking it one step
further she my mom now so
is one of the samuel 365 certified
mentors which is just insane
so that means that you know when you
when you go to book a call now
you're going to get my mom you're gonna
get tony and tony crook as you know is
my
mentor you got alice stare who's who's
one of my best success students like the
the quality of the mentors on samuel 365
are just it's just ridiculous i mean
it's just really
the other training companies now are
just saying we quit
we quit like how can we compete 95 pound
a month
and you just get unlimited mentoring
calls with
millionaires and stuff like forget this
we quit
so you know it's it's it's great and
it's and the only reason we put this
together is for everybody on this call
you know the fact that we've got people
on the membership um so thanks so much
folks for being for being um for being
customers
and students i'm going to interview my
mum sue
um ask her some questions about some of
the deals she's doing then i'm going to
give an opportunity for people to ask
questions to me
and to her uh while she's physically
with me and then
and then we're just going to open it up
you know and ask me anything session
about any type of property strategy
anything at all um we're going to open
it up
and then we're going to get some
successes uh i'll pull some people on
it'd be great to hear from khloe i know
we spoke last week we said what do you
need from myself and the team
um keith good to have you on the call as
well
uh sean and don bradbury again it's so
good to see
sean and dom on the call you know i mean
sean is don's dad
i i think i think i'm right in saying
that i'm right i'm all right sean are
you definitely are samuel yeah so great
to see you know because like i've just
been i've just been in huddersfield with
a guy called tom
and tom's tom's done a rent to rent in
huddersfield which is going really
really really well
and you know i met his mom and i met his
dad and and then
you know they were quite skeptical but
now they they're really proud of what
he's doing and they can see the results
paying off
um tom's just done the deal selling
masterclass he just sold his first
deal this afternoon um he's doing a brr
deal
a joint venture with his mom which is
just beautiful so i'm just like i'm just
really loving
i'm just loving what's going on in the
samuel 365 community
and if you've got deals you know some
juicy deals going on at the moment
and you celebrate on here it's snowballs
because i'll be then being like
let me come to your house let's film it
you know let's stick it on youtube
next thing you'll be on winners
wednesday um aaron pina really good to
see you i was trying to call you
actually i don't know if you got my
message
um erin i was trying to call you but it
was like a switzerland number so i
couldn't get through um
but yeah we'll we'll catch up on this
call as well but hey i just all i wanted
to say is i just wanted to say massive
congrats to have you on the e academy
um you know super super glad really
smart decision
so i hope to speak to you this evening
if not i'll try call you again and hope
it hope it hope it goes through
um but yeah so apart from that is anyone
feeling good if you're feeling good just
give me a wave let me know you're
feeling good
amazing amazing um if you're feeling
rough and you've got questions and you
feel stuck we're here for you we love
you we support you
so you know hold those questions if you
don't get your question answered tonight
book a mentor and call and um let's just
have some fun so mum
come on round you want to bring your
chair up
great this is like the most exclusive
you know excuse me
you know so thanks so much
[Music]
all right great so firstly um why don't
you just tell us a little bit about the
deal that you've just
refinanced because you know the ones you
have to value because that property
is is you know a really juicy little
deal so
give me the figures and and tell the
story actually tell the story
of how you found it and what happened at
the auction because that's a
really incredible story okay so uh
myself and my husband wanted to buy a
barn like a really
recommend to do it because we thought it
would be cool
and exciting and we live in the peak
district
so we've been looking around gone to
millions of auctions
they'd always gone sky higher prices and
then we saw
this lovely little barn and it was at
auction
starting at a hundred thousand pounds
so we thought um that'll go sky high
that will
so let's try and buy it pre-auction
so we rang up the estate agent um and we
said oh we're interested in buying this
barn
um and we'd like to give you an offer
pre-auction for
and just as we were about to say a
hundred thousand because we thought it
would go sky high
they were like no no no we've been told
we can't take offers
let's roll play how the conversation
went okay so you be
i'll be i'll be the agent or do you want
me to be joining the agent
i'll be the agent okay this is literally
what they did so um um
yes 32 church road yep it's going to
auction how can i help
yeah right well we'd like to give you an
offer before auction
oh we cannot accept on any offers before
you come talk to you just turn up on the
day
it's on for a hundred you need to come
to the day ready to offer a hundred
okay don't tell me again okay but we
were going
just come to the auction on the day
minimum a hundred thousand pounds
okay all right i'll see you at the
auction okay that's what happened
literally right
that is actually what happened they
literally put their fingers in their
ears and went la
la la pretty much yeah exactly so you
tried to ring up you tried to offer a
100 grand pre-auction
they wouldn't even let you say a hundred
grand they were like no turn up on the
day yeah but then what happened
turned upon the day decided that 100 was
our top
figure and there was hardly anyone there
and we bought it for 80.
it's just funny isn't it give her a
round of applause by the way folks
that's incredible
so so so turn up on the day go ahead
parade
it if i was the owner of the property i
would be
firing that agent i mean to not even let
you get your words out
that just shows you guys how stupid some
agents are
you know and we see agents all the time
maybe they're like
you can't even view it until you give
proof of funds you're like
what is wrong with you people do you
want to sell the house
have you not been instructed to sell the
house do you want me to find the title
deeds of the owner and write to them and
tell them how [ __ ] of an agent you are
like what the heck is going like that's
how i feel sometimes
but this is this is like you know how
how it can it can backfire on the agents
um and of course you you know you want
to have good rapport with agents and
stuff
so you went to the auction you were
thinking 100 minimum
so you're thinking 100 maximum but
you're thinking we probably won't get it
got it for 80 grand how did you feel
when you bought it
you're over the moon right yeah so you
bought it for 80 grand yeah
then what so there was a lot of work to
do on it which we knew
um but this is just for the record this
is like a
small completely run-down
barn like you know um
not even run down run down's not the
word it's like an animal house
yeah there was nothing in it right like
looks just like there's been horses and
hay
and stuff like that in there that's kind
of what it was like um
but it's very very small like extremely
small
smaller than how many square foot is it
you know not sure
it's a holiday probably about probably
50 square feet
max i would say but anyway it's a bit
bigger than that i don't know
okay go ahead what happened what
happened so uh
yeah so the previous owner had actually
put a roof on it
and done a little bit of work to it and
then realized because it had to have
planning permission always realize it
was a bit of a nightmare
and sold it and that's how we mistake we
got it in very long
garden very long garden in fact my mom
did something really interesting with
the garden which i think
i learned a lot from i was like so the
garden was really long
but because of how thin it was there
wasn't really anything you could do with
the garden it wasn't actually you
couldn't get planning permission to do
anything with it it was just a long thin
garden
so what she did when you're trying to do
a project
in the peak district or anywhere
especially trying to get planning
as a holiday left which was the
intention you kind of want to get the
community on side
you know if you've got local farmers
that don't like you it's not really
helpful
so what my mom did was she actually kind
of not donated but she
said to the local farmer next door she
said do you want to just use this
this garden you can have your sheep on
it and they can eat it you know you kind
of donated it to them
yeah it's a half an egg yes massive
yeah so we've cut off the bit we want to
put a stone wall there
and the previous owners didn't get on
with the farmer next door
so we've asked the farmer if he wants to
use this extra bit
for his sheep so he loves us now he
loves you good relationship
but also now you've got a free lawnmower
right
the sheep so you've got a free lawnmower
now it's still your land you're still
only
just given him like a free lease almost
effectively unofficially
so okay so then you what did you do with
the barn
yeah so then um we renovated it
um and it's finished practically it's
just got a few little
outside bits to do but yeah it's
practically finished all the inside's
finished so you bought it for 80. yeah
we only care about three figures man my
students only care about three figures
they don't care about
what you did with the garden or how how
nice the the farmer
is you care about three figures so give
me these three figures i want to know
purchase price i want to know doing up
cost
and then i want to know what the value
are not what you think you know what the
agent said
what is the value of value the property
app by the way guys
this is juicy so you want to get get
this go ahead
okay so 80 purchase price yeah the due
up
um was 55 55 so then totally took him
135
yeah we thought it would be 50 but it
was a bit more 55
yeah we had it valued last week and it
was 200
200 grand or awesome awesome awesome
give her a big thumbs up big thumbs up
so so so you're going to refinance it
yeah you're going to pull out all of
your money yeah maybe even more
and then you're going to rent it out how
you're going to rent it out it's a
holiday lot
okay so you could do service
accommodation yeah and and how much
roughly a week
are you going to get for that about five
hundred pounds a week
and a week is that on average or that's
gonna be um no a bit more in peak
average maybe five hundred okay so
average two thousand pounds a month
no money down using the brr strategy
also using the service accommodation
strategy
you know and this is just one of you
since then you've done i mean that was a
few months ago now you just finished
that off you've got a load more going
through what else you've got done at the
moment
uh we've got a couple of houses in
warsaw
in the west midlands where we used to
live um
we've just renovated one the value last
year was 175
we've spent 10 000 on it
and it's now valued at 2 15. nice
cool and then there's another one which
we bought
last year um it's an ordinary
three-bedroomed semi
but it has a huge side garden
and back garden so we've got
we put we've just put in for planning
permission for two
two bed terrorists on that land so what
we're gonna do
is renovate the house and then sell that
for more than we bought
the whole plot for which is like a free
plot basically
free plot and you're going to build on
it or just build on it
yeah great so you know
my mom's my mom's my mom still got it
this property thing
um doing super good stuff so if anyone's
got any
questions you know maybe about that or
or or particularly about you know
right now i'm gonna do questions in a
bit like about rent to rents and all
sorts if you've got any specific
questions about these types of
strategies
be our own stuff um you know then then
just jump up and go ahead and ask
hey sue
did it have planning permission on the
barn beforehand and were you nervous
buying at auction
i've never bought at auction i've always
wanted to um
but you know what i mean like you kind
of feel like my mom don't get nervous
okay fearless i guess
go on um we have bought at auction
before um
i'm a little bit like excited i'm too
excited
at auction but yeah it did have planning
permission
a level of yes going into it that you
were going to have an exit
exactly the planning commission was
really detailed
um in the peak district they're very
tight with the planning permission
they told us what color to paint it how
the windows had to be
everything now exactly had to be like
that so we just stuck to it
um i wasn't really nervous buying from
auction it's just same as anything
yeah oh god of a question
oh yeah go ahead go ahead david um when
you actually
viewed the property what intrigued you
about it to make an offer before you
went to auction
what was the biggest thing for you
the location we were looking for a
holiday let specifically
in the peak district and it was half a
mile from
a beautiful village with pub and shops
restaurants and all that
um but it was also kind of like in the
middle of nowhere
yeah yeah edge of the village it was
just the location lovely
well that's it man look at you man
that better yeah right anybody else got
any questions if so just jump up
yeah go ahead peter hi both how are you
doing
um yeah we're going to see a house
tomorrow the wife and i
uh that were quite fancy it's in it's in
1.1 acres
it's got a uh a three bed out on it
already
i reckon we could probably cut half of
it off and do another
development on the back of that plate
and obviously with you
with you kind of dealing with that
already i wonder how easy it is to kind
of
get one getting planning in them areas
and then
to get the um get the permission
to and the money together to develop it
because obviously
i've heard that you can get you know not
like you can get it fully financed can't
you
i don't know anything about it so be
useful we live near there we live in
sheffield so it's
in sheffield this place okay
well first of all if it's something like
the planning permission depends on the
council
yeah if it's like for us in the peak
park
then it's really hard to get planned
commission to build then it's
virtually impossible yeah if you're not
in a park you're not in a conservation
area
then it will depend on things like the
layout of the road
because some roads they only want you
know just one big house per plot
so that all needs to be looked at so you
might be able to ask an architect
you know just get an architect's view on
it beforehand
yeah and so funding wise
if you own the land then there are some
funders that will give you a hundred
percent
finance but it depends on the deal
you've got planning permission
if you don't own the land you have to
put a big deposit down okay can i
answer that question as well obviously
so
in terms of whether you're going to get
planning or not i think that the best
way
i'd be able to answer that question is
the thing that the councils care about
is is it fitting and is it in keeping
with the area
right okay i'll give you an example
right we're looking at buying a piece of
land
one minute from my house piece of land
is a big piece of land now it's over
half an acre
and you can easily build four houses on
it
is it however it's in beckons field
and beckons if you're gonna build four
houses they're gonna be like
terraced houses you don't have terrorist
houses in beckham's field you have
mansions
so the council are gonna go hey that
isn't very in keeping with the area
so the council when you're trying to get
planning
i used to think the council were my
enemy i used to think that you know
i've got to try and get planning and
they're going to make my life difficult
actually the council and planning is
fair
and they're my friends because not only
do they want me to win
as a property developer because there's
a shortage of houses and they want more
houses but they also want this to happen
when i'm driving down the road i'm
thinking this is nice this looks
beautiful
when i get back from most countries okay
if i'm traveling i get back to england i
always get back and i'm on the right way
and i get home
this is nice everything's clean and
green what a nice country we live in and
that's because
of the councils making sure that
everything's in keeping everything's
tidy
so you know if you want to know if you'd
be able to get planning on on
on the land i would say well in the
street
has it been done before you know what
what just
maybe even maybe even go on google earth
and zoom out and look
and just think it would be fitting we're
buying a piece of land on on
we're supposed to be complete tomorrow
actually friday's our deadline um
we're completing on a piece of land
whether we'll build on it or not i don't
know
we might just get planning and then sell
it off for planning or you know who
knows exactly what we're gonna do
but if we um there's gonna be two
options with planning one
one option will be because profit is
profits in the planning usually so
usually if you buy without planning
you're going to be limited on how much
profit you can make
if you buy without planning you can make
a lot of profit so
a good strategy is to buy get planning
and then just you've got to worry about
the build or anything that's what we
were thinking
yeah but this land we've bought now it's
got laps planning 10 years
ago for five apartments so we're going
to try and build five apartments but if
we can't build farm apartments
we know we're gonna be able to build two
houses how do we know
if you look down the street it's like
two a couple seconds a couple cents
couple cents couple semis
big space kind of be pretty fiddly
a couple it's not gonna be difficult for
us to persuade the accountants let's
build there
when we know as well because we can look
on the website it's public information
you can see
is this area in need of more houses you
know so
i think that's you know that's just a
few things i'll um
kind of say on that point does that help
pete yeah that's really helpful thanks a
lot cheers
cool you're so welcome so welcome maybe
one or two more questions for on this
topic
and then i'm going to pick on some
people to share some stories and then
we'll do some we'll go into some more
questions if anyone's got any burning
questions from my mom
can i answer yeah go ahead sam so it
might be a bit of a stupid question
but development wise is it very
complicated and dangerous because
i've had an agent offer me a development
deal
she emailed it over to there and i don't
even have a clue
the first thing to start on it so i've
just ignored it
yeah i think if you don't know what
you're doing then you do need to get
some advice to be honest
look do you see me teaching development
on youtube
do you see me teaching how to buy land
and build houses
probably not why not because i know that
some dum-dum
is gonna watch get inspired go do it and
go bankrupt
they're gonna be upset with me so what
do i teach on youtube i teach things
like rent to rants
yeah your packaging safe stuff the more
money
the more reward the more risk the more
risk
the more you get you need to be so my
advice fam
would be don't don't i wouldn't say like
i'm not gonna look at it who cares
but but be very very very careful if you
don't know what you're doing because
when you're talking about building and
conversions and
stuff like that you know it it it's it's
my job is to make things simple not
complex i'm not trying to say don't do
it i'll put you off
i'm just saying there's a lot that can
go wrong so make sure that you have got
good people around you you've got the
right advice you've got you've done the
right training programs etc
yeah it was like a really really big
deal that got offered it was like 1.2
million in crew
cool so right
okay thank you all right you're so
welcome sam uh go ahead gemma
hi yeah um i just want to know what your
biggest um
learning uh you know your biggest lesson
was
of your recent refurbishment
oh um
okay so i've been in property for quite
a long time
but we've never done a barn conversion
and
my biggest lesson was i was glad that it
was a small barn conversion that we did
first
because you know like um samuel was just
saying to sam
everything's scaled up you start on
small things and when you get confident
you scale it back
and that's what we're going to do now
we're going to scale up but i'm glad
that the first
one we did we didn't really know people
that could build in those
limestone bricks we didn't really know
people that could
fit treatment plants and all that and
we've done all our practicing on that
nice little one
and now we're ready to go bigger
that's brilliant so do you think that
you'll look for more bonds as like in
your kind of niche now
i wouldn't say it's my niche um
we're kind of spread out with our niche
we wanted a couple of holiday let's but
i wouldn't say that's just what we're
gonna do now
okay fab thanks thanks welcome i'll ask
you a question samuel
go ahead keith um how did you go about
finding the right builders for the
project
for me well we didn't know anybody we
didn't really know the area that well
although we do live in the peak district
and we've not done any building up there
before um
we went to local builders
sites and suppliers and asked for a list
of people we used mybuilder.com
um and then we just got loads and loads
of quotes and
to be fair we had a few uh
recommendations and they turned out to
be really rubbish
so we ended up just finding our own on
initiative and
and yeah just getting them down and
seeing what they were like
and when you say they turned out to be
rubbish did they start their job and
then you have to get rid of them and get
somebody else or did they not get that
far
no they didn't get that far they kept
letting us down right
and that kind of thing if the if a
builder here's something really
interesting as well i'll say about
builders on
on your point is if they're not very
good at the start
if they're not returned if they're not
if they if they're arriving late
and being sloppy and they haven't
started the job that's how they're going
to be right through the get-go
so you best have to quickly you know you
got to be really hardcore
if they arrive late or if they go oh
i'll start on monday and then on monday
you get a text
at 9 30 go oh my daughter's been a bit
unwell so it's actually going to be next
monday forget it
can't even turn up on time on the first
day you know
and the other thing they did was some of
them they gave us a quote
and then they increased the price so
like a month later when it got near to
the time they were going to do the job
it had gone up so we were just like no
or when you try and get an itemized
quote from them and
timelines with penalties if they go over
the timelines they're like really funny
about it i'll forget it
how much do you charge for builders how
much do you
we don't charge builders at all actually
they charge us
in that respect yeah no sorry um how
much did the builders charge
i think i think it really depends on
what on what the job is and what the
type of builder is
um i mean wildly
it varies um it can be a couple a couple
hundred pounds a day for
their actual labor um some charge by the
job
and some charge by the day so it also
depends where you are in the country it
can vary massively as well
like it depends what you're doing like
if you're getting someone to fit a
kitchen you might pay him 150
you'll buy the kitchen get it from
howden's you might spend 1500
and then it might take them three days
to fit it they'll probably charge you
500 quid
you know that's a kitchen but then if
you're doing if you're building a house
you know it's quite hard it's quite a
hard question to answer
but i hope that gives you a little bit
of a ballpark
i was trying to kind of gauge a rate you
know
a rate for what though an hourly rate a
daily rate
materials possibly hourly or daily
well about 200 pounds a day okay
all right thank you and that's pretty
much
it welcome all right so i'd love to i'm
going to pick on a couple people
or if you want to pick on yourself you
can but i want to i want to hear from
some people that are winning
i want to hear from some people that are
really killing it i don't know if tom's
on the court i was with tom today
is tom is tom on the call
hi samuel hey what's happening tom
not much i'm good thanks how are you
well you say not much but that wouldn't
be
entirely true would it not at the moment
now it's actually been quite busy today
so tom today
sold his very first deal
and and from you let me tell you
something about tom
tom works as a swimming instructor he
also does rugby gets actually paid to
play for his national
it's not national for his local rugby
club 18 years old
right he's been working his bum off
for the last however many years and he's
been saving his money and guess what he
did with his savings
he bought the deal selling masterclass
and he didn't feel good about it in fact
he was how do you feel tom
um well it was i i've saved up my life
savings kind of thing since i was
born just turned 18 and i was a bit
skeptical
skeptical about investing in the
training um
but i can't thank samuel enough for the
training it's been great and if it
wasn't for him
then um i wouldn't have just made two
thousand pounds today
congratulations my friend so he made two
thousand pounds which by the way
he's already that means you've already
made a 200
roi yeah that's the thing people don't
people don't
think like this because oh it's the
ground well you've made 200
roi in the last month but on top of that
what else have you done tom
so i secured my first uh rent to rent
deal about a week and a bit ago as well
18 years old man secured a rent to rent
deal weekend a bit ago
and how's that panning out for you yeah
that's going really well so we've got uh
one tenant in already we've got um
another tenant in
um this weekend and we've got
loads of inquiries and loads of viewings
for the other two rooms that need to be
filled
amazing stuff you also are doing a
little brr
in huddersfield yep so that's um a joint
venture that i'm
doing with my mum actually and i've told
you today
i was telling you about my mom today
when i was with you yeah
because he's working with his mom and he
was saying to me it's a bit uncool
though isn't it working with my mom
you know it's a bit uncool doing a joint
venture with my mama and i was like
no i said i didn't i i was i was doing
the same thing when i was
18. you know you've got to take the
cards
you've got and you've got to deal them
you know and you've got to be grateful
that your mom is actually in property
and is happy to joint venture with you
she didn't give him a penny
just how like mama didn't give me a
penny but you know you've thought
let me try and and i said you just keep
adding value adding value
so you've got a little jv how much do
you how much do you guys buy that house
for in huddersfield
the uh purchase price for that was uh
sixty thousand pounds
uh we um the refurb has cost ten
thousand pounds
and we're hoping to get it valued at a
minimum of 85 000 pounds which will
leave us with
7 000 pounds in but 85 the minimum if we
can get it at 90 that'll more or less
pull
all of our money out nice solid
solid deal 18 man i mean
very very very solid and it was a real
pleasure meeting you today tom in person
and um the whole philosophy i have you
know very much like that it's like you
make one move
i'll make 10 you know and i think just
by having
samuel 365 you know like it's getting
that
us ready to do that so you know make
moves and see what happens
because honestly i'm constantly on the
lookout i mean i said to gemma edens
i got confused actually i messaged jen i
messaged gemma yes then before yesterday
i was like looking forward to seeing you
tomorrow and she was like
what i'm not meeting you tomorrow i got
mixed up but we're meeting next month
so you know it's people say sam how much
does it cost for me to come and meet you
one-on-one i'm like
how much it costs is you putting your
all into this business because i don't
charge
to me i didn't charge tom to come and
spend in a half a day with him or
anything
i just did it because i wanted to
because i saw what he was doing i
thought he's 18 he's
he's taking names and kicking acts i
need i want to go meet him i want to
meet his folks and
see what he's up to and that's the case
of a lot of people so massive massive
respect times you know what if
anyone want to ask anything for tom if
so feel free to jump in you know
yeah i have a question actually hey
ollie by the way
congratulations for registering for the
e academy man thank you thank you
appreciate everything that you've done
actually so really
i phoned you up a couple days ago as
well um just after the um
the uh freedom formula intensive yeah
you did thank you for that by the way i
appreciate it
anyway go ahead what's your question um
so yeah tom so massive congratulations
on your first deal with the brr rents
aren't absolutely amazing i'm a new
academy member
so i i wanna i wanna find out a little
bit more about what you've done
so how the process of your first deal
and did you do a um a bridging loan for
your um for your brr with your mum so i
just want to find out a little bit more
okay so the first deal was the rent of
rent and that came about
uh basically through the local estate
agents uh
sending a letter through the purse um
basically inviting company let's
um so i had a look on their website see
if they had anything online that was
appropriate at the moment
and uh the house that i secured um was
up for
the uh 575 so
i called up and i basically said that
i've seen that you've advertised this
i've seen that you do company let's
um and i'd be really interested in
taking that or anything else that you
might have
and uh within a couple days i had the
keys in my hand
and then uh with regards to the um the
joint venture with my mum
um we haven't by the way i have to give
a shout out to your mom because
you know she's got a letting agent in
the area again she's been in property
for a real long time but and i know i
said this to you earlier like
having having a family that support you
and and
prepared to do things like put
properties in their name and stand with
you and do joint ventures and stuff
it's just so so valuable and for anyone
that doesn't have that
that's what we that's what we're here
for we're here to be your property
family
um but you know i to have to give a
shout out to you folks um
and also she was even on the crash
course you know she was on the she came
to the crash course with you been in
property for like 20 years or whatever
um you know so you know mad respect
what's that i think she might be on the
call your mom is on the court
i think she might be dude now i'm going
to be embarrassed hold on let me
if you're on the call tom's mom you can
jump ruth you can jump up
hello oh goodness
well there we go you know what do you
never talk bad about people behind their
back because you never know when they
could just be in on the call
so it was great it was great spending
tommy today ruth
yeah really enjoyed it really fun
probably one of the most fun days i've
had in property in
20 years oh wow that's saying something
that's something well i learned a lot
man i learned a lot about huddersfield
and
the different and it's really
interesting as well i was talking to
ruth who's tom's mom
about how in property you can sometimes
you can sometimes get a little bit in a
rut sometimes not saying ruth did that
but because the property that tom got
the rent to rent
ruth's thinking rent to rent sounds a
bit strange how does this work you know
and and then was thinking can you rent a
room out with no ensuite in huddersfield
does that
you know but tom came and it just
succeeded it just worked so sometimes
just challenging the status quo and
stuff
you know what did you think of tom's
rent to rent ruth oh he's done
fantastic you know he's still at school
um and he's out there in between
his online learning lessons absolutely
killing it
and just you know spending hours every
day
searching the internet for deals
networking as best they can through
covid
he he's just putting hours and hours in
and it's all paying off for him because
it's
after a few short weeks it's all coming
together
great and everything as well
people would say don't do that that's
crazy you know be careful whatever
so to have that kind of support and
moral support is just awesome so anyone
else any questions for tom or for ruth
go ahead and ask
tom hey tom question
um could you tell us a little bit more
about that deal you sold
what was the deal uh okay
so it was um a single let in
huddersfield
it was um two bed um i actually
if you're on the crash course at the end
end of january i actually presented it
on the crash course
um tom hang on tom did you find the deal
at the crash course yes
i mean come on folks this is getting
ridiculous now
so tom came to the crash course
when you came to the crash course have
you been to a crash course before or
no no i've never had any kind of formal
like training in property or anything
like that what were you thinking when
you came to the crash book how are you
feeling
um kind of skeptical i i knew it was 12
hours long i thought is it really going
to be 12 hours full of
amazing content and then i stayed till
the end and it absolutely was
i can't believe that and if i remember
right you got you got
ticked off with me because you didn't
win 100 pounds
well i thought it was the best deal yeah
you found it but you were upset right
that you didn't win the hundred pounds
a little bit yeah but then you ended up
getting 20 times that
because you just sold it yourself yes
dude that's awesome so nice single left
good roi
who was the investor that bought it and
where did you find him uh sir
the investor he is um
not bad he's he lives in wales
and uh he has quite a good job quite a
little bit of money
and uh basically um
he actually got in contact um
he's known my mum for a while and i knew
that he had quite a lot of money
um and i knew that he was invested uh i
knew that he was interested in investing
in property uh so i just uh dropped him
and a couple other people in the same
situation a message and
all those people messaged back within
about two minutes
and within he was the first person on
the firm
um and i had him convinced within about
five minutes and then sent in the
invoice and had the money in my bank
and you were messaging me man on
instagram you were like dude
dude what do i send him
i'm i'm driving home right from from
huddersfield today
and i see a little instagram post pop up
from tom like a message
i'm thinking tom's just i've just been
with tom like what's he what's he
missing so i literally pull over
at the little phone booth i'm like right
what's tom saying listen to his voice
now drop him voice right back
you know and that's the thing that's how
dedicated i am to seeing people win
when when people are taking action and
when people are doing stuff and when
you know so tom man massive massive
props to you for doing that for selling
that deal
finding the deal for doing your joint
venture with your mom for doing the
rent to run all within the space
of like a month or so yeah
just like just under three weeks i'd say
absolutely incredible man
absolutely incredible anybody got any
other burning questions for tom
just a quick one here yeah yeah go ahead
um hi tom i'm terry um really great
story really inspirational
um the deal that you're working on at
the moment the property
um that you're doing a br
how did you source that i'm just
interested to know it sounds like you've
got a good deal
um well it came upon it just came up on
uh right move um it was
um my mum that actually found the deal
wrong to answer that question because
that's also an interesting story
yeah and you guys viewed the property
together and stuff but i know it was
your mom that initially found it and
it'd be great to hear the story of how
you found that vr deal this was a deal
on right move
with an estate agency called yieldit
they specialize in selling properties
with tenants
in um i saw the property on right move
and noticed it was cheap for a
three-bedroom house in the area
compared to you know the usual sale
prices
so um i called the agent
and he said um yeah it's for sale at
that price and a great
what's the catch and he said well
actually
um that the catch is it's got a
um sitting tenant on a regulated tenancy
so
pre-1988 the rents they're on
basically you can't
evict them um
now i say well you know thank you very
much but um
it's not going to be for me um because
the yield was basically too low
so then um that was that
about three weeks later he called me
back and said oh by the way
just found out that um the
um the landlords let me know that that
tenant is moving out are you still
interested in buying
and i said yeah when can i look and he
said today
i said great we'll be there so we went
looked around the house
it had 40 years of nicotine stains on
the wall
but i knew that you know it was a really
good buy because i
previously sourced a property opposite
that one for another investor seven
years ago for 56
000 so i knew this was going to be a
good deal at 60.
there's one just along the street from
that
was recently sold 100 000 so
so yeah straight in there with the offer
for
60 000 um we'll be spending 10 on it and
i'm hoping it'll value 85
90 000. all right
and i'll say something else as well
about that deal
ruth and tom came out of the viewing
there was a couple other people around
the house right
as they were leaving the door they were
on the phone
putting forward an offer that's how
quick you have to be
most people think well i need to think
about it i need to sleep on it i need to
spend a few days i can sort of see
people
you know but actually you don't there's
not that many facts you need to put
afford on a property you need to know
you know what are the other houses
selling for in the street
quick complete that on right move how
much is the refurb roughly going to cost
doesn't take long to work that out if
you know what you're doing you know so
just a few basic
and then you can put forward an offer
you know no messing
so that property was being rented out
the tenants had been in there for 40
years payne's
peppercorn went because they they were
protected tenant
the price was really low but then when
the tenant left by a choice
it snapped the property at the low price
so phenomenal story
and it's great to hear you know people
and that's the thing you know the
purpose of these calls is also to
networking to hear what other people are
doing and to be inspired
so you know do connect with tom and and
ruth um
you know but that's that's incredible so
hey guys um an input joe what what
what's happening joe joe nicole what's
going on
hi man how are you i'm really well good
to see you what's uh
have you have you working on any deals
have you have any any successes you want
to share
yeah we're doing the deal at the moment
i'm working with um anthony anthony
wilmot
um well he's helping me out um on a deal
with a brr
um we've been on a call for the past
year with aleister and ricky which has
been uh
amazing really so we're gutted the
finish but it's exciting to try
something different to meet some of you
guys
so dude this is this is you know
net network is everything you know so so
it's
it's really good to have you on it's
really good to have you on the porn
excited to hear about your deals
also as well great to see angie cherry
who's well on the call angie you might
remember
she was on a windows wednesday literally
like a couple weeks back um
working on some great stuff and you give
us a little update i've seen you busy on
socials and stuff what's happening
um viewings lots and lots and lots of
viewings um
and also trying to get my flats up and
ready and ready uh one's rented
one isn't um and uh basically the
market's changed slightly so i'm trying
to get everything done as fast as
possible so i can revalue at the best
price and pull
all my money out plus um several tens of
thousands hopefully
um so that's good and um yeah just um
i'm just looking for some more brrs at
the moment um
so um fingers crossed on that uh it's
all looking pretty good i'm
quite buzzed actually um all right what
is patricia on the corner she's been
doing some awesome stuff as well be
great to hear
an update from patricia hi patricia
what's happening
hey what's happening yes give us a low
down
um yeah so uh well today was fun um so i
got to meet
um anthony and david taylor today for
the first time
uh which was just really really
wonderful
um we looked at a barn conversion
together and
uh it's gonna be a really cool project
um but it's just so great to
like you work so closely with these
mentors every week you're speaking to
somebody
and um they're so involved in everything
that you're doing and they're so helpful
and so it's really really touching to
sort of see them in real life
and uh and sort of you know get get to
know them a little bit better so i was
really grateful for that i had a
mentor call with ricky this morning or
this afternoon
which was great and um yeah so just full
full with a lot of property family love
right now all of my peeps are on this
call
everybody like i'm scrolling through
these pages and pages and i i see all of
these people who i speak to
on a daily basis on a weekly basis and
we're all really um helping each other a
lot of people here i've had
one-on-one calls with like ange and just
everyone even
hannah like and then everybody else um
it's just
it's great it's great i'm really excited
awesome
um anybody else's that done some deals
wants to share
i would like to share something
somewhere i don't know if you remember
me
uh the last crash course i want the best
i do remember very well on the last call
of the summer 365 last one this
wednesday
i reached out to godzilla because
obviously italian you know
folks and i thought oh i'm just gonna
make a connection there
yeah and i explained for my from my of
my ideas of last week at the crash
course two weeks ago the crash course
and she seems interested so i said
obviously i just started you know
i haven't i have no idea what i'm doing
i'm just out there
and a graziela said yeah it seems great
india so she's trying to sell it for me
so i'm really really happy it gave me
the bump to just you know
crack on and carry on absolutely
fantastic hey great job
i knew you'd kill it especially got
evans and lauren and david on the call
right now
i mean they've been on the court every
week since the financial freedom
challenge they don't have to they could
say you know what
i'm good now made a load of money got
some rental rents
but every single week they've been on
the call why do you think i picked to do
the financial freedom challenge with
them
because they're probably going to become
financially free anyway
i just wanted to do it quick and take
some credit like it's not me
it's them you know so i'd love to hear
what
maybe i'm being too harsh on myself and
my input i don't know but like
i'd love to hear some input of like
lauren and david
and evans hey hey what's going on people
that you do the ff challenge with
it's people like you say you know you
they take two steps forward you're gonna
take them steps with them as well you
you can't make people do the hard work
you can only show them how it's done
and then once the jumps off the cliff
you know they've got to grow their own
wings and fly
i refuse to even come in the meeting
with you to get your big development
deal
yeah that's true that's true because
otherwise there's no point in you coming
in with me every single time for every
single meeting for
every single even estate agent meeting
correct because when you're not there
how am i going to do it on my own
correct how have you been getting on bro
the last couple weeks oh it's been
crazy it's been absolutely mental we've
just completed on a couple of investors
projects
one this week one next week and then a
refurb just starting there turning them
into hmos um
we've got a deal that's packaged up and
sold
this week already i've not even sent it
out to anybody i only told one investor
and he's took it already
so i'm taking him up to see it on
saturday and
just networking you know showing up
doing what most people
won't do every single day you know i'm
at that point where like
obviously everyone knows like i don't
have to have a job i'm just doing this
full-time like
you know i could stay in bed all day if
i wanted to
but that's not going to get any type of
results at all no
so it would be absolutely pointless so
every day i still wake up i'm out the
door for like half eight nine
and i'm on the road i'm viewing i'm out
and about meeting people
you know what here's my advice to every
single person on this call go to a
financial freedom challenge
just do it you know don't wait for me to
come to your house obviously you guys
are already on 365 and trying
but like just go do it just say you know
what i'm going to book a week in my
diary
i'm going to block it out i'm not going
to do anything else i'm gonna do a
financial freedom challenge
and and and i'm gonna you know just see
what happens
i'm gonna put pressure on myself and and
because but you know what you know the
pressure we put on ourselves when we do
the financial freedom challenge like
it's real you know it's
real um evans anything to say yes yes
yes i mean you pretty much just uh um
you know hit the nil on the head um i
mean your presence that week was amazing
it definitely
had a huge influence but like you know i
have to put all the work
um so i think you could not you could
not phrase it any better
um you know your training is amazing
best friend i've ever had
however it's not a magic wand you're not
gonna you're not gonna like become
successful for osmosis
like you have to put in the work um so
one thing i'll say if anybody
you know looking at this even today a
guy was a guy who's asking me today is
like
like how how well do you know samuel are
you close to him
you know do you have his numbers like
yes like like this victim every day was
like no
just like why did i'm like because it's
it's not like i don't need samuel but
i kind of like donate samuel let's go
it's giving me all the training already
you know he's giving me a platform to
win so
i'm not going to bombard him because i
don't really need him to obviously do
he's given the knowledge it's a system
that everybody can obviously plug into
and win
so ultimately um what was it to anybody
obviously
you know looking at this life right now
is that you don't need me you don't
insomnia
um you know all you need to do is take
the training you know copy and paste
don't try to change any you know you
know anything
um and yeah you can do it man you listen
if i can do it like
like you guys you guys on the court
right now don't know me like you only
know what you see on
on youtube but you don't know me she
knows me and she can tell you like if
everything
can if heaven's gonna win in property
any tom dick and harry can obviously do
it
i i can assure you that so um so yeah
like me and evans didn't not me evans
and ellen i should say
the three of us did an interview um in
fact it's just gone up on youtube that's
evans
and that's yeah we just did a full-on
interview you know
following on from the challenge like a
windows wednesday interview and it's so
inspiring
you know you need to listen to these
guys get down to winners and listen to
their interview
and and evans you know in a rough place
man evans was suicidal
not too long back you know the bottom
the bottom the bottom
um we didn't even talk about that on the
on the financial freedom challenge or
anything
but you know it was a bad place and now
he's him and ellen my goodness
he says he doesn't need me anymore but
he still messages me all the time asking
for help
[Laughter]
dude some of the stuff you've been
asking me for they've actually been
legal stuff as well
yeah i know right you know so super cool
david what's good so as i say evans
logan
you're definitely right i do get people
contacting me saying
you know what i would love to do an ff
challenge for samuel but
your presence is there you're really
putting the pressure on us
we have got the knowledge from your
training you know it's no different to
anybody else we've done
the 365 it's on the dsm and it's just
putting pressure on yourself every week
you have to hold yourself accountable
because if you back off
nobody's going to move on to your life
and give you results you really have to
go out there
you will get bad days but it's just
keeping be persistent
and the results do come i'm so excited
about
your your financial freedom challenge
coming out no i can't wait
you make lauren look like such a [ __ ]
the way you just walk in the park
[Laughter]
how did it happen how did me and lauren
go to
every single agent in manchester and get
rejected
and then me and david walk out with a
freaking signed contract pretty much
on our very first visit to an egg like
it blows my mind but david
we smashed it and i know you've been a
lot since the challenge as well which is
just incredible
um i said these guys did the financial
freedom challenge with me
you know massive props to them all
because they all did they all put the
work in and they all got results and the
reason i chose to do it with them was
because i knew that they put the work in
and they did
apart from lawn it's a bit lazy but
he knows i'm playing i pick on lauren
because i know you can if you take a
joke because he's
he's very muscular and i'm very jealous
but hey can i just jump
in quickly and just highlight something
so i was just before we jumped onto this
call i was watching evans he's um
winners on wednesday and he mentioned
something where he said
you know he thought that he worked hard
and i thought the exact same thing like
he thought that he worked hard i thought
that i worked hard until you came to our
house
and then i was like [ __ ]
this guy is like a machine like he
graphs like don't get wrong i'm out
every day
i'm dressed i'm i'm you know i'm ready
to kill every single day
but literally like you are on another
level so it was just like a shout out to
evans for saying that because that looks
like
i've literally only watched about five
minutes then jumped onto this car watch
the recipe afterwards but when he said
that sentence i was like i know exactly
what it means
like anyone could do a financial freedom
challenge at any week
you just do what you're gonna do but
times it by ten
yeah that's probably a financial freedom
charge about a hundred that's probably
an ff challenge
me and lauren do stuff together like
like we have i have a car crash
it slows me down five minutes my dad
five minutes out having a car crash he's
gonna slow me down five minutes
because i'm not going to be like i've
had a car crash let's talk about it
viewing i'm using it to my advantage i'm
like getting to the viewing i'm like hey
we just had a car crash get into this
viewing you know you need to you need to
be kind to us now missus estate agent
like the lich know i was doing that
you know turn everything to your
advantage i'm not taking calls from my
wife
when i'm with my wife i'm with my wife
when i'm working i'm working
i'm not mixing stuff up when i'm in the
shower i'm in the shower
no i'm serious because some people have
just constantly got all these thoughts
all over the place
you know and but they're not actually
getting anywhere
me i'm in the shower i'm enjoying the
shower and then i'm getting out the
shower and i'm
i'm just focusing on what i'm doing at a
time you know i think that's i think
that's super
i said now super important when i'm
meditating and clearing my mind and
speaking to god i'm doing that
you know when i'm when i'm when i'm
working i'm working
and when we do the financial freedom
challenge we're working all the time
unless we're sleeping but that's sure
you know we get up and we work we don't
we don't we don't stop breaks and food
you know i remember i did my financial
freedom challenge you know and i
remember
evans was like can we stop can we stop
to get get some uh to get some food i
was like
to me that was a strange thing are you
going to
stop the middle of the day to go and get
some
food i said what do you want to eat you
guys i was thinking chinese i was like
brother
are you joking maybe we'll swing by a
petrol station and grab a sausage roll
maybe
but stop for china what you're kidding
me brother do you remember that evans
come on yes sir yes i remember i
remember loud and clear i was i was
starving well i've been like look
i think i was day free i was just like i
need some proper food samuel a louder
you know petrol stations it was like
chinese are you having a lot it was just
so funny
very fast was that
[Music]
thing is it's like people that say to me
samuel can you come and move into my
house
they wouldn't want me to move into their
house believe me
24 hours they'd be begging me to leave
the house believe me am i right david
you know what it was intense because
you just don't you don't sleep you just
start first thing in the morning
samuel's there is on the phone two
o'clock in the morning
sam is still on the phone putting he
goes did you make interference and you
book anything
you just don't stop and as you say about
thinking ahead i was going to you one
day well what are we going to do
tomorrow you
just focus today yes that's really
interesting point actually
because because i remember with i'll
come on to you in a second julia
but i remember um i think he was when i
was with you david i can't recall
it all three of you a little bit but i
remember it like we were out trying to
find a deal
just it was actually i think when i was
i don't remember you can tell me
but i remember when we were out trying
to find a deal because we need some
money
we needed some cash and the person i was
with
was trying to line up a rent to rent
we'd view the rental rate
and i was like forget that right now
we focus on one thing that's it was that
you david was that evan i
can't recall maybe it was all three of
you but it was just like today's
this day right new day now we focus on
getting the rent to rent next day right
now we focus on getting a lease option
agreement or getting
all the paperwork signed we're not doing
anything now stop trying to sell a deal
we're not doing anything until we have
the paperwork signed we're not phoning
our wives
we're not eating we're not doing
anything until we have paperwork signed
that's kind of like our financial
freedom challenges is structured
i don't know what you guys would have to
say about that if that kind of brings
dragons to you or nodding
i thought it wasn't me with the rent to
rent was it no it wasn't you
[Laughter]
what are we gonna say yeah i said that
is true because i can record i think it
was the second day i was just like
samuel i've got this house for ellen
what do you think should we book a view
this is like look
we're not booking a viewing we're
getting renter instead i was like
okay but you know what like literally
even if
even on friday i was in bucks yeah last
time i said exactly the same thing
just focus because what you taught me
that week like
like it's just chilling i mean it's not
bad it's not about what i achieved
it's about what i learned from that week
it's just like it's crazy man it's just
like i just focus on one thing now
one thing only so uh well done to you
man thank you so much i'm not no no no
it's real cool and you guys are gonna
love seeing david's david go ahead
yeah we'll say one thing because even
your flight was on two o'clock on a
sunday you had to be at the airport and
you still
insisted having a meeting uh on that
sunday morning
you know a business meeting so it just
shows you you actually don't stop
you know and this is right up until the
last minute so yeah
it just takes the effort and anybody can
do an ff challenge themselves
they can't they can't the thing is that
what most people we would
when we're trying to achieve in seven
days what most people would achieve in
seven years
or in never you have to work like a
beast
like you just cannot and i don't work
like that all the time by the way folks
like i do have time off i do take time
off
um but but when i'm working i'm working
oh wow okay
um so i've just come back from the world
today i got back about an hour ago so
that was really cool can you hear me
yeah yeah i can eat right
oh no that's good um i spoke to her i
reached out to rosella
and she she kicked my brain in gear i
just thought come on take some take some
action get get moving
so um so i've gone to the world twice
i've booked in with sandy to go to
doncaster
um next week and i'm i'm i've got
i'm clearer about what you've just said
strangely which is
take action on that day get out there
get looking i'm confusing myself a bit
but i've made i've made three offers
and one of the questions i was going to
say to you if they don't pick you up on
it
do you just walk away forget it move on
or would you go back and revisit them
okay great question
so what i would not do is i would not
wait and and and and just think oh i
forgot an offer
let's and give it any mental thought
it wouldn't it's not going to sit on my
brain okay that's the first thing
because a lot of people put forward an
offer
and then they wait to hear back before
they take any action to do anything else
what you need to put forward an offer in
them next in terms of
um would i ever go back yes i probably
would
um i would write down that you've put
forward an offer if you can
i mean if you're organized enough to
just have a little notebook or a little
one yeah
i've done that every time you put an
offer just write it down write down the
address
the agent um the right move link and the
amount that you offered
yep and then and the date that you
offered it okay and then what i would do
is
every every couple of few weeks just
ring up and go hey how's it going you
had any um
at all do you know what as well um
something that i've done
quite a few times is and it you can say
it's almost a bit mean but it's just
something that i sometimes do
is i'll offer on a property so let's say
i have for 102 500 it's always specific
my office
100 to 500 i'll put it forward i'll then
ring back after two weeks and i'll offer
just slightly less
i like that slightly less
right i'll ring up hey i know i offered
102 500
two weeks ago but um i'm just ringing to
say that i've revised my offer
and my new offer is uh 101 500.
you know that's on the that's on the
table right now you know for the next
for the next couple days let me know
the agent will come back to me oh they
said no all right call no problem i'll
ring up three weeks later
hey my office is 99 500.
you know and can i say that
david taylor is absolutely awesome
because i
it's silly i do deals in the id space
and i'm fine
but i i made it i wanted to make an
offer on this and i suddenly got to the
weekend and i went ah
what do i do and i sent out some emails
and david just rang me on sundays he's
just
awesome and and just talked me through
what i was trying to do
and i think most of it was what i was
doing was okay but it was just that
reassurance
it's just you can't underestimate it it
gives you real confidence
and he's as you say he's the kindest man
and he was really
really really nice and the other strange
thing that came up this week
is i saw a link for crowdfunding
and i thought that's an odd way so i
thought i'd put a question on facebook
to say
has anyone thought about doing craig
crowd funding for
for sourcing for properties
well as an individual or going to a
crowdfunder
well both i suppose but yeah i thought
it was an individual yeah
i guess there's two ways you could do it
number one is you could go to an
existing company that does crowdfunding
like for instance crowdfunding property
by someone sushi and you
have a deal in which case very similarly
to almost a bit like bridging
they'll lend you money they'll want to
charge etc yeah it's a very reasonable
way to get money
um another way would be if you were
trying to do it yourself
ia you get a bit of but then you
definitely want to get legal advice on
doing that because there are
okay you're not fca regulated and you're
trying to get people to put us
money in and they're not um accredited
investors there can be there can be
issues so
i'll probably seek legal advice before
doing that but yeah it's awesome
thank you last week i would just once i
was absolutely
overwhelmed last week at the
reviews that came flying in like
honestly
it was i'm not kidding it was the
highlight of my entire week
the call was fabulous the support the
love and
i we had we had about 100 people leave
a review on either trustpilot or google
every single one was positive every
single one was genuine
i don't know why it happened single call
i always ask for reviews
and normally patricia kelty and
graziella
lee yeah like normally like
two or three but like honestly i was
just overwhelmed and i was just
i was just saying to my wife amanda like
on the wednesday morning i was just like
i don't know why everybody is just
suddenly taken to
social media to start leaving reviews
and stuff and raving about what but
i was just really really touched so you
know i just want to say thank you
um thank you for that i'm i was very
very very grateful
i know graziella i saw i saw um i i
grazie has left me a lot of reviews but
uh you know just massive massive
massive respect and and thank you you
know because it makes it worthwhile for
me as a trainer uh if i haven't had the
opportunity to speak to you this evening
or if you haven't had your question
answered um i think it was just it was
did
um did julia did you have have you been
wanting to speak i think julie did and
then i'm gonna
pass about the ff challenge i wanted to
say sorry coming back to that point
uh that i found that really really
inspirational and i think it's great
what you do with people and that was one
the
really tricky question will you do an
international so outside uk ff challenge
one day
i've done one you know you don't want to
no i did want i will i'll go i didn't
know
number one i did one in ireland no i
mean outside
i mean when i mean outside uk means
outside like
euro in europe number two i did one in
america i didn't know that in america
where are you from italy maybe i'll do
one in fact i do want to do one in italy
i've got some really interesting things
come on somewhere
but right now i've just done three
financial freedom challenges pretty much
back to back
so i i've created a new term and that is
i am ff'd
out right now like okay no but but but
sure i i i i definitely would be open
too mine please
i'm open to anything i'm just i just do
spend things spontaneous i'm up to
anything
i like you so much because you're so
open to challenges that's why i wanted
to have
challenges i'm open-minded and i just do
things off the cuff you know
spontaneously
thank you absolutely um okay guys
um let me just say about the reviews
yeah
i i put a review on and trust file it
yeah then they wrote to me um
trustpilot wrote to me saying no we've
removed the review for now we need you
for you to explain a bit more
and i there wasn't anything too detailed
in there so i wrote i replied to the
email
and then i got another email back the
day after she said no we've completely
removed the review
really strange trustpilot are very very
strict
with reviews if they if they sense that
the review is not completely genuine
for whatever reason they don't they
don't allow the review whether it be
good or bad
um but that's really strange i'd
probably suggest just maybe trying again
and even
i did actually read your review because
it did show it must have disappeared
um yeah i think you actually credited
was it dave taylor or one of one of the
mentors
um i did read it so i'm not sure why
that happened but um
you know i didn't put any links in there
or anything like that to like take you
to the web pages or anything like that
so i don't know why they
they questioned it thanks for it maybe
try again
and um yeah all right guys well listen
folks
thank you so much as i say for the
reviews last week um great to see you
all
have a wonderful week kick ass
uh if you get stuck book a call if
you're on your trial of samuel 365
if you're on a trial by the way if
you're still in your trial give me a
wave
okay there's quite a few people on the
trial great well we hope you stick
around
um it's 95 pound a month unlimited
mentoring weekly calls
and and natalie brown that's great julia
great
um thank you gemma that's awesome and if
you get stuck give us a shout we
appreciate you we love you
and i can't wait to see you at 8 pm next
week if you haven't left to review
already i ask every week
get down to trustpilot samuel leaves
trustpilot leave
leave um leave a review if you haven't
already and
we really really appreciate you so i'll
see you next week 8pm
and in the meantime go kick some ass and
get some deals
thanks bye